well when i was nine my dad was in
prison
and i he told my grandma to let me use
his phone for my birthday
so um i was going through his pictures
and i found a video and it was him
raping me when i was four
and then when he got out i confronted
him about it and it started happening
again
so
all right faith faith where'd you grow
up where are you from originally
oklahoma and tell me about your
childhood you had both your parents as a
kid
i have one parent mom
dad dad what happened with your mom she
went to prison when i was six months old
and my dad left there
oh wow and i met her one time
but she said that she came to visit me
but she came to get divorced paper
signed
that's really all she came for but she
called me from prison like
a few weeks ago so you never really had
a
mother figure no
and tell me about your childhood any
traumatic events any abuse at 14 i was
kidnapped
um a guy named jaquan robinson he's in
jail right now they're trying to get me
to go to court he was arrested in 2017.
he kidnapped you and did what um locked
me in the closet
and had people come pay him to rape me
pretty much
that's how i got brought into this kind
of life
because i was connected yeah but you met
people that
started pimping you or something he was
pimping oh he was okay yeah
oh wow and rather than stopping that
kind of
behavior you continued well i went home
after i was kidnapped and like
everybody just like treated me different
you know and i just felt like oh you
guys think i'm not [ __ ] anymore because
of what happened to me so since they
treated me
wrong i just went back so
how old are you now 16 16.
and uh do you still have contact with
your family
no some of them yeah but
does your dad know you're out here
he knows what i do he does has he
tried to intervene or anything yeah
but he just really minds his own
business he's not really worried about
me
so you've been doing uh sex work for how
long
huh you've been working as a prostitute
for how long since i was kidnapped in
2017 since you were 14 years old
and where did you go from oklahoma did
you start working there or uh
in 2009 i moved to california
and i didn't start working until i was
kidnapped
i didn't know nothing about any of this
do you feel like that event kind of
changed the course of your your life
yeah sounds like it
and so today you're working figaro
street
you have a pam i have a boyfriend yes i
understand
and you bring your boyfriend the money
you make
no it just stays in the room we share it
okay
and you're fine with that arrangement
it's good for you
he takes care of you yes he does
so how many how many guys a day will you
or a night will you
entertain a lot
i don't know it's just hard right now
because like
i'm pregnant so are you ready yeah two
months
your boyfriend is the dad mm-hmm
are drugs at party early no not anymore
not anymore
where were we using before crystal
crystal meth helps you get in the mood
for all this
kind of stuff well when i was kidnapped
he would like force me to do it so like
i think i just got addicted you know
so that was a pimp that you met in
oklahoma where he met you
no i met him in california city and
um he was with my step-sister
and she was the driver when i was
kidnapped he paid her
can you make enough money you're saving
money you think i don't save no
no no i need to
where do you live do you live just motel
the motel
yeah right now i'm trying to get a
studio apartment though
you had any bad experiences other than
your kidnapping since then
um my dad is a child molester so like my
whole life
like was just hard
did you ever have sexual interactions
with your dad he had sexual interactions
with me
that's what i mean yeah yeah
oh what age did that start well
when i was nine my dad was in prison and
i
he he told my grandma to let me use his
phone for my birthday
so um i was going through his pictures
and i found a video and it was him
raping me when i was four
and then when he got out i confronted
him about it and it started happening
again so
that's why i just stay as far away from
him as i can
in living this life do you get depressed
you get
anxious all the time i have scars on my
arm because i used to cut myself
because you cut yourself
oh wow all the way up
i don't do it anymore though
and did some of your customers get rough
with you as well
no you ever had that well there was one
like the other night
he kind of got mad that's why i have a
mark right here
yeah i see the bruise on your arm too i
know that's
that's from a while ago it just won't go
away
so this kind of work does it build your
self-esteem somehow or does it undermine
your self-esteem
well since i was kidnapped i suffered
from ptsd
it used to like make me feel better
about myself because people would pull
up and tell me i'm pretty and of course
stuff like that but now like after every
day i want to cry
and all kinds of stuff because i'm
supposed to be on psych meds but i don't
have any more
because i suffer from major depression
bipolar depression
and ptsd and
your the guys that will date you do you
respect them do you
do you like them
i just put up with them
are you in love with your boyfriend yes
i am you are
how old is he 27 27
what do you think the most misunderstood
thing is about this
kind of work a lot of people drive down
figaro and think all these girls just
love sex and
they don't see the bigger picture behind
it it's not easy for everybody to get a
job
you know it's quick easy money you don't
have to fill out no paperwork
nothing and really most of the girls out
there
are girls with really low self-esteem
who don't
care you know and going out there just
makes them feel
better because people will pull up to
you just to tell you you're beautiful
you know
yeah how far did you go in school
huh how far did you go in school eighth
grade
do you find it difficult to be
surrounded by people that are all up to
up to no good
you know what you're doing is illegal
what your boyfriend's doing is illegal
what
what the customers are doing is illegal
i don't really care
you've been doing this for a few years
now how do you feel like it's changed
you
i used to be a good little white girl
i used to go to school i always had my
nails done
i dressed a little hoochie but that's
just because i thought i was pretty you
know
but after i was kidnapped like
everything just
went into a down spiral
i stopped going to school started using
my family disowned me neglected me
so really
since my family wasn't there the streets
were
you know i didn't have nowhere to stay
no money to buy no food
i was underage it's not like i could
just go get a job you know yeah with an
eighth grade education it's gonna be
hard to get jobs done yeah
you ever stand back and look at your
life and just think this is such a crazy
life compared to maybe who you went to
school with some of your friends back in
oklahoma
or even california i talked to like
people that i went to like elementary
school with and stuff in
california city and like
all doing good got cars
houses jobs and i'm just like damn that
could have been me
it could have been me
but i'm thinking about going back to
school yeah
you're still you're 16 so you can yeah
easily
change the direction of your life
because i want to go to college for
victim advocacy
good for you yeah that sounds like a
great idea
well i'm going to be a d.a victims
advocate and then i'm going to do like
public speeches and like places that
can't afford
to have people come visit schools and
stuff
that would be a great idea i'm going to
do free volunteering what would you tell
a young girl who's been through some of
the traumatic stuff that you've been
through
how would you advise them it's other
ways to deal with your emotions
it might be a little bit more work
to find the things that will help you
get through them
but this ain't gonna help yeah it's like
you're recreating the
traumatic event that happened to you you
live it every day
yeah whereas with a little bit of
courage you can
use that as fuel to go in a better
direction
yeah for yourself and perhaps you can
teach others to do the same
sounds great do you believe you deserve
a better life than this
because this is i do that's great
i mean just as an outsider who just met
you i can tell you you do
it's very clear to me that that's what
you should be doing something
like your friends from school yeah are
now doing but
uh but i understand what you went
through is it almost
after it happens to people it's almost
you become like a moth to a flame and
you end up
going right back to the same kind of
behavior or something that'll recreate
that behavior
the abuse the disrespect the lack of
love all that stuff
by going back into it you're not
helping yourself
you're just putting yourself back into
that same situation
what does this kind of work taught you
about
about human nature or about men
everybody's different yeah
that's very true
you can't judge anybody because i'm the
one out there
you know
i don't know what's going on in these
people lives to have them
paying for females you know
you get asked to do things that you're
uncomfortable to do to do
like without have sex without a condom
sometimes but i just tell them no
yeah if i don't feel comfortable i'm not
doing it
you believe in karma i do good and bad
there's a lot of karma stories in your
life from what your dad did to you and
i know and it's gonna get them
and the decisions you've made for
yourself also
you'll pay a price for that down the
road and if you change the direction of
your life you'll yeah
change your karma as well see the thing
is i have
time to change mine yeah but don't waste
it
a lot of people you know start in their
teens and they never ever get out
i've talked to a lot of women in their
50s and 60s i think
and they're still doing this that's them
i'm me
good for you good for you
what about your childhood do you think
if if it was different if it had been
different
might have changed the direction of your
life
having your mom probably yeah
i would think that would be a big one
what have you learned
from doing this kind of living this kind
of life
but what mistakes have you said oh my
god i need to never do that again
i don't know you make mistakes to learn
from them so i don't really repeat the
mistakes that they
do you sometimes find guys that want to
pick you up and
you're afraid to get in the car with
them yes
actually i was in bakersfield and that
happened to me
and i was still walking and the guy
ended up parking
and getting out and running up on me and
tackling me and all kinds of stuff
it was so crazy my friend was on the
phone right down the street i was so mad
you know and with a child on the way do
you think
that'll motivate you to maybe get out of
this line of work
it's already motivating me good for you
it's nice to hear all right faith well
thank you so much for talking with me
thank you and i wish you and your baby
the best of luck and uh
[Music]
i hope some of your plans come true
all of them will good for you thank you